have a freeway closure you want to make
sure you are aware coming out of the
spaghetti Bowl heading towards the
rainbow curve you're gonna have to get
off at Jones a multiple car critical
injury crash at the rainbow curve again
no confirmed fatality at this hour and
it's a little bit hard to tell from this
picture but this is the 95 kind of going
around the rainbow curve there's at
least one rolled over vehicle somebody
else on the exit ramp to get off at
Summoner Parkway so multiple cars
involved the bottom line you're being
diverted off the 95 at Jones so you're
saying well that's all great but how do
I get back on the freeway we have two
suggestions for you first of all you can
go north on Jones up to Lake Mead and
then take Lake Mead West that'll be your
next exit if you're going north on Jones
now you can also go south on Jones down
to Alta or to Charleston get over to
Rainbow and then go north on Rainbow
that'll get you onto the 95. the rest of
the freeway looking like a regular Rush
Hour again we'll keep you posted with
the complete closure of the 95 at Jones